[Music]
to another exciting episode tell us and
it's with great pleasure I'm able to
bring to you my latest statue and then
you can see it in the background
yeah that's Thor breaker of brimstone
and the concept behind that statue is
basically is a menage of thor ragnarok
thor endgame and Thor the new Thor in
the books so you can tell that's not
classic Thor's outfit that's when he and
when Ragnarok came and Asgard was
displaced and they decided to go to
Midgard which is Earth and make a
residence there Thor came back with that
new suit I like it
I do like classic Thor suit with the
yellow boots in the leather straps but
I'm a bit outdated you know we all know
what that is and in his hand you might
see that Thor has two hammers those two
hammers is Milner and Stormbreaker
millionnaire is Thor's original hammer
no that's what Odin gave him that's what
he earned as a child to be able to
possess the power of Thor in the Marvel
Universe in MCU they want you to believe
that Thor is
himself the conduit and the hammer is
it's just a focal point of his energy
that no that Thor is the power source
and the hammer is the conduit the power
to focal point his power out of it and
that's just not true
all right Thor has a base level of plus
100 tons in comic book talk that means
that he can off divert just off the rip
fresh freestyle left a hundred tons all
right
and that means that he's in that plus
100 ton category as being the son of
Odin yes he can control the storm yes
the storm is his command and the hammer
is made of euro metal which is a special
magical metal that is magical properties
only can be found in Asgard and it can
only being be found where the FAR's
giants dwell and the dwarf the dwarfs
make the hammers and make the materials
and make the armor out of this year old
metal which is highly durable so I know
when your soul Thor Ragnarok and hella
broke Thor's hammer it was mind-boggling
all right and then you know when they
did infinity war though I had to go get
a new hammer which was Stormbreaker you
know we all know about Stormbreaker that
read comic books and Stormbreaker
is actually the gold hammer that you see
back there it's actually the gold hammer
it's not dead
elongated ax type hammer that you see
now that hammer as actually a thing is
not made from roots arm in the comic
book at with the with the shaft pause
but um that hammer is from the Ultimate
Universe
all right this two separate universe
and emerged them that's why the MCU is
based loosely off of the ultimate
universe that's why you get a lot of
stuff than you some work familiar with
and not familiar with and if you read
the ultimate universe of book line with
Miles Morales that stuff spider-man
who's Hispanic and black you would see
that they used that universe a lot more
because it's grounded in today's reality
all right a lot of our books were
grounded before I mean yesteryears uh
you know a society and it doesn't work
for now that's why the MCU are highly
successful because the ground the
characters in a realistic format now
back to the statute the dynamic polls on
this statute I needed to have it soon as
it came up for pre-order peel um P order
pre-order I had to get to statute I
believe that this is a turning point for
sideshow the the level of detail in the
statue at the base the base is actually
suit Souter's head now hard for me to
say you know New York with my New York
accent um but Souter it was in thor
ragnarok he is the flame demon who grows
really tall and he is supposed to
breathe be the bringer of Ragnarok he's
supposed to be the end of Asgard he's
supposed to be the destroyer of all and
it's foretold in the prophecies that he
will be the demise of Asgard
so that head his head is the base
alright so you're getting a little piece
of everything with this statue you're
getting thought and there's new suit in
this dynamic pose which looks fantastic
you're getting Stormbreaker and you're
getting mil ner alright and you're
getting throw with the new helmet
everything looks fantastic this statue
is certified probably one of the best
now this is the first time I've ever
seen a statue go up from Pele pre-order
and get pushed ahead months ahead I
think it really had to do with the
coincide with the UM with the movies and
they needed to get this out before they
broke um you know like I guess they have
probably had MPD's on it or something I
don't know
but if you saw at the end game I mean
I'm a vendors end game then you
understand throw welded both hammers at
one time and in doing so this shows you
that he was doing so now I know a lot of
you guys would rather his body look like
dents and I fat door out of shape door
but we all know and the books Thor is
actually supposed to take the place of
Odin Odin is a robust trunky man when
you grow into manhood and uh Asgardian
law you understand they drink their
party and he you know what's on that man
wait all right there's no longer the sex
symbol that you guys want to see but
they get that back when he goes with the
guardians of galaxy
yeah I just destroyed the movie for you
you should have saw it already cut it
out um true fans already saw it well
you're working to go see it spoiler
alert all right now this statue will
probably remain in my collection for a
very long time it's very rarely that
you're gonna hear me say that you know I
got a statue that's up for sale you know
you can get that statue is up for sale
very really that you're gonna hear that
but this statue is gonna stay in my
collection for a very long time I do
appreciate sideshow for going the extra
mile if you look at it the whole statue
is either made in poly stone or resin
and with a mild mixed medium mixed media
is the Cape okay now with that cape
that's the material part but the other
part of the statute is all poly stone or
high gloss resin and it is beautiful
it's a tall statue and
as an arrow any type of bass is a deep
bass it's a very three-dimensional
statue as a statue that you would like
to walk around and see now some people
keep asking me where the Stormbreaker
come from quick synapses all right
Stormbreaker was made for beta ray bill
beta ray bill beat Thor and even
contests right and that was they were
fighting over mill NER now what happened
is butyrate bill is the lone protector
of his species the species was in a ship
that was orbiting Earth Thor went up
there with Nick Fury to check out what
was up there when he entered the ship it
started be - ray bill to defend his
people and he wrestled Thor for the
hammer and actually gain possession of
the hammer when he gained possession of
the hammer he got the power of Thor okay
and in becoming worthy and having the
power of Thor he fought Thor beat Thor
they went back to Asgard Gordon said I
check it out I let y'all fight a fair
one you know and then fighting a fair
one Thor got knocked out almost died
beetle ray bill saved him and took him
back and he needed the hammer to help
protect his people to find a planet so
they can flourish on wooden swords plate
said this guy is pure of heart and told
the dwarfs within a fashion him a hammer
any fashion Tim Stormbreaker that
Stormbreaker the gold Stormbreaker it
was a beautiful story line by wall
Simpson the odd directions are always
beautiful I always thought that he did a
great job on Thor and introducing a
character that will stand the test of
time invader a bill which I believe will
be in the new MCU going forward
I couldn't ask for anything more so guys
that's a quick synopsis on where
Stormbreaker actually comes from inside
the comic books and not the MCU and MCU
it was made to be Thanos that's not a
thing in the books all right
so stick around like follow and
subscribe and also go to Lords of gaming
dotnet you can get the latest on the
gaming news great opinion pieces and
also where you can catch other shows
like other king of the statue
hey all other combat talk with the king
and episodes of iron Lords podcasts I LP
which I'm a member of alright so if you
like me here you'll love me there and
also tune in to the last word with loyal
Cognito
and Lord and bonta's you can get all the
later latest looter shooter news it's
great stuff with great friends and a
beautiful chat trying to bring the
community together guys got a couple
more weeks to e3 tune in stay engaged
and always leave me comments so I can
work on the format and I can get it
better it's gonna change we're gonna
actually get inside that throne room so
you can see more stuff but music coming
up pictures coming up and more videos
coming up stay tuned
Thor break off brimstone happy to
debuted for you guys see you next week
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]